Speaker 1: Remember that you can sign up and
get a membership to the David Pakman show
at join Packman dot com.
Not only our memberships, our primary source
of funding very, very important as we are
now in an election year, you also get a bunch
of great perks, including an extra show every
day that we do called the bonus show commercial
free audio and video streams of the show,
priority access to viewer town halls and so
many other great things.
Sign up at Join Packman dot com.
You can use the coupon code.
Wow.
Twenty two.
It's an impressive discount code.
OK.
The Trump Riot Committee wants to talk to
Fox News propagandist Sean Hannity.
And why wouldn't they?
I mean, at the end of the day, this is not
a big shock.
Sean Hannity became I don't know if we can
say friend Trump doesn't really seem to have
friends in the way you or I might use the
term.
But he became a colleague or associate of
Donald Trump's regularly talking to Donald
Trump and clearly was involved as the riots
and the attempt to steal the election were
going on.
The House Committee investigating the riots
now wants to talk to Sean Hannity, and they've
released some text messages that are stunning.
Not in that Hannity is suggesting crazy things.
But in that it makes clear that Hannity knew
what was being done was a bad idea.
But then he went on to tell a lie after lie
after lie about the 2020 election on his show
and about the Jan. six, 2021, riots on the
program.
Axios reporting January six committee requests
Sean Hannity's cooperation.
They have requested Fox News Channel host
Sean Hannity voluntarily voluntarily cooperate
with the investigation.
Hannity is one of the most prominent media
figures in America, was a close adviser to
Trump throughout his presidency.
The committee revealed last month that Hannity
texted then White House Chief of Staff Mark
Meadows during the riot to urge him to get
Trump to stop his supporters.
Hannity condemned the attack on the Capitol,
saying on his show on the night after the
riot that all of today's perpetrators must
be arrested or prosecuted.
But Hannity has never criticized Trump for
his role in ginning up the crowd in D.C. that
day, and he has criticized the congressional
committee investigating Jan. six article from
The Daily Beast revealed Sean Hannity's other
desperate texts about January 6th.
I'm very worried about the next 48 hours,
he texted Mark Meadows hours before a MAGA
mob's violent attack on the Capitol.
We can't lose the entire White House counsel's
office, Hannity wrote to Meadows on December
31st, 2020.
I do not see January 6th happening the way
he is being told after the sixth he should
announce will lead the nationwide effort to
reform voting integrity.
Go to Florida.
Watch Joe mess up daily.
Stay engaged.
When he speaks, people will listen.
It's not terrible advice from Sean Hannity.
It's not what Trump ultimately did.
But the committee wrote to Hannity that that
message quote suggests that you had knowledge
of concerns by Trump's White House counsel's
office regarding the legality of the former
president's plan for January 6th.
Jan five, 2021.
I'm very worried about the next 48 hours.
The committee further asks Hannity, Why were
you concerned about the next 48 hours?
Incredible.
Incredible that the public facing stuff Hannity
was doing reflected a 180 degree different
perspective on what did and was taking place
than what Hannity was texting behind the scenes.
Same could apply to Laura Ingraham, as we've
talked about before.
Here is Adam Schiff appearing on MSNBC yesterday.
Asked You're looking for info in cooperation
from Hannity and Adam Schiff says Yes, we
are.
Speaker 2: Are you looking for information
or for cooperation from Mr. Hannity?
Speaker 6: Yes.
I think you'll see an announcement about that
very soon.
You know, we believe that he was texting with
the chief of staff and that he has information
that would be relevant to our committee.
He was more than a Fox host.
He was also a confidant, adviser, campaigner
for the former president.
And I would hope that if he's asked by the
committee, as I expect, he will be very soon
that he would cooperate with us.
Speaker 1: Unclear if that will actually happen.
Congresswoman Lofgren was also asked about
Zoe Lofgren.
Asked about why Hannity and she says, Well,
we have dozens of texts from Hannity.
Take a look at this
Speaker 2: activity is a fact witness we have
in our possession dozens of text that he said
to Mark Meadows and others in his role as
a political operative.
Indications of his communications with the
president and others on strategy.
And it's that that we would like to talk to
them about, want to make sure that everyone
knows this isn't a subpoena.
We've asked him to cooperate with us as a
fact witness out of his sense of patriotism.
Yeah.
Speaker 1: Well, good luck with that.
So we'll see if Hannity does show up.
Another very interesting text that was published
by CNN's Brian Stelter, highlighted by Brian
Stelter relatively early on.
Quote guys, we have a clear path to land the
plane in nine days.
This was nine days before Biden was sworn
in.
He can't mention the election ever again,
ever.
And clearly, Hannity saw, even if not out
of a moral duty to say, Trump's got to stop
this stuff out of a strategic duty to the
Republican Party, Hannity saying he's got
to stop with the election.
We can land the plane.
He can go to Florida, criticize Biden, but
stop talking about the election.
Obviously, that's not ultimately what happened.
And this all makes Hannity's promotion of
lies, conspiracy theories and the like even
more vile, even more dishonest, even more
immoral.
I don't expect Hannity to cooperate with the
committee, but let's see if he does.
Quick note I don't want to spend a ton of
time on this, but Donald Trump has decided
to cancel the event that he had planned for
tomorrow.
Trump was going to do a press conference at
Mar a Lago, his Florida resort, tomorrow,
January six, 2022, the one year anniversary
of the Trump riots on January six, 2021.
He has now canceled that.
Maggie Haberman from the New York Times says
that quote, among other things, several advisers,
former formal and informal, told Trump the
press conference was a mistake, and it was
becoming clear he wasn't likely to get the
live TV coverage that he was hoping for.
So there's actually two interpretations of
Trump's decision to cancel this.
One is he realized there's no way to spin
what happened last January 6th in any way,
in any way that would be remotely advantageous
to him.
That's one possibility.
Trump's ego tends to push in the other direction,
which is I can always spin anything to be
good for me.
So the other interpretation is Trump got word
that the major networks were not going to
be carrying that press conference live and
decided it wasn't going to get the publicity
that he wanted.
And that really does anger the guy.
So that has been canceled.
Important.
Donald Trump will be appearing at a rally
in the state of Arizona, not this Saturday,
but next Saturday, January 15th.
And he has put out a statement saying that
then he will offer his thoughts on what happened
on January 6th, so he'll eventually speak
about it.
But rather than being in front of what was
destined to be a small television audience,
he will do it in front of a live audience
on January 15th.
We'll have more information about that that
may also get canceled.
But the Jan. six, 2022, press conference Trump
had planned for tomorrow at Mar a Lago is
canceled.
Make sure you're following the David Pakman
show on Instagram at David Pakman show.
We're going to take a very quick break and
be right back.